à la réduction du temps de travail elle
doit être à partir d'un certain âge
35 heures c'est du baratin pour quelque
80 en oubliant une hausse des calanques
à 5 ans tient pas quand elle a 55 ans le
bruit il va c'est deux fois plus sa
maîtrise rare raison de lui quand tu es
jeune d'ailleurs ce qui est la vraie
façon de contourner le problème et jean
35 heures c'est de la pub c'est 40 ou 45
1 parce que tu as 30 octobre en même
temps à mai et alors ils veulent et là
dessus sur les 45 heures alors qu'elle a
beaucoup qui sont pour il ya beaucoup
qui sont contre qui et pour qui et
contre 6 que vous réveiller bien là on
va demander la plus jeune d'entre nous à
moi je trouve qu'il ya une logique dans
ce qu'il dit il en fait ils revendiquent
heures de travail par semaine pour les
jeunes ont déjà bien après tout dépend
de la pénibilité ou pas ça mais
franchement
s'il ne serait pas horrifié que qu'on
fasse cette mesure d'accord répond alors
complètement horrifié pourquoi pourquoi
les jeunes il sera encore discriminés
pourquoi 35 heures pour tout le monde et
pas pour les jeunes parce qu'ils ont la
niaque oui alors s'ils ont la gnac il
s'arrange avec leurs patrons si leurs
patrons il veut payer des heures sup ils
accaparent les heures sup tout s'inverse
et ça c'est vous que tu vas dire oui on
va dire non il va pas d'heures sup l'un
il pas si spécial à 45 heures ou de 35
heures mais tu gagneras plus femmes et
oui mais tu gagneras plus comment avec
des heures sup ou sur la base du smic
horaire à temps sur les amis à
travailler mais presque renseignez-vous
sa baraque des heureux avec un salaire
normal cela s'est passé il ya raison
raymond si on les a mis là jouent bien
mais pourquoi tu feras dans lui c'est 45
heures 45 heure sur la base de 35 heures
sur la base du smic d'accord avec pas de
récupérer 1 45 avions non je suis non
moi je suis sûr et certain soit m $ 10
oui je suis pas certaine que ce soit
légal je pense que tout le monde serait
au 35 ans n'avait pas il va changer la
loi mais toi tu sais que tu crois quoi
la durée légale que benayoun j'adore
elle accroît c'est mon cousin
je pense qu'il ya une durée légale et
qu'au delà de ces pas du tout mais
le lancement il veut changer la loi
j'imagine c'est qu'ils vont faire qu'ils
vont faire effectivement secteur par
secteur étrange das par tranches d'âge
avec des mots tout cas il faut 45 eur et
oui c'est sûr ils aiment changer la loi
c'est ça il faut changer la loi et moi
je suis scandalisé parce qu'android les
jeunes c'est vrai que vous qu'ils
foutent rien dit sauf de la pandémie on
va augmenter les droits d'inscription à
l'université
c'est très compliqué la boue main encore
un coup sur la tête des jeunes je suis
pas sûr qu'ils jettent pas ça en pâture
pour voir et comme il ya beaucoup de
réactions hostiles qu'il abandonne
est-ce que les gens qui ont dit avec un
joli vainqueur voilà presque pas ils
sont avocats et c'est plus facile pour
eux parce que quand on est dans une
usine et que c'est super compliqué
peut-être qu'on n'a pas envie de
travailler 45 eur donc est-ce qu'on veut
pas faire du cas par cas est ce qu'on
peut pas être cermeno com annonce légale
géraldine sinon c'est n'importe quoi
c'est ça le fait nicolas boyer vraiment
que c'est ok mais
soyons sérieux ouais je négocie alors
manama écoute massy au cas par cas
faudrait des fenêtres
durée légale comme vous le savez c'est
35 heures en rouge sur ce qui existe
déjà n'empêche qu'il ya déjà des cas
particuliers ben voilà il ya par exemple
dix heures par jour et 40 heures par
semaine pour ceux qui travaillent sur
les chantiers de bâtiment les travaux
publics ou la création d'espacés
qu'à moi je suis pas 35e mais ce serait
unique mais ça touche les jeunes de 16
17 ans quand elle danse a tenté de
foncer à l'épreuve et k way un coeur pur
rencontre que tunis s est installé comme
enfin ça dépend
16 ans tu vas des
noms manhattan ont marché sur la valeur
guillaume s'il te plaît mais c'est une
grosse du style assez non mais c'est une
mesure polémique mais qui colle à la
réalité il ya plein d'entreprises qui
doivent sur le papier à respecter les 35
heures et on sait que c'est vrai que les
salariés travaillent plus et ne sont pas
payés au moins ça mérite de coller à la
réalité mais je suis pas sûr qu'ils
venaient pas je pense qu'il veut
légaliser le fait qu'on puisse
travailler 45 heures dans une entreprise
mais si c'est légal et seront payés ça
chante non qu'on ait un bas salaire brut
par mois sachant qu'au final les ya déjà
cinq heures supplémentaires qui sont
autorisés par semaine je vous signale
mais c'est à dire sans même qu'on est un
pays où il ya les 35 heures mais on est
là où on est les plus produits
écoutez ça va ou alors il votre avis
j'écoutais commandes ce qui faisait le
valais
mieux sur une prochaine là que des
annonces anti démago parce que ça c'est
pas démago le pass vaccinale c'est pas
des masses la
tendance et 32 heures dans certains pays
nordiques ont besoin de deux heures et à
boire et toi tu étais tu étais de et toi
tu deviens complètement il ya vous faut
c'est le productivité parce que les gens
s'impliquent énormément et c'est la
grosse tendance il a un ça va mais on va
travailler à chaque vote serré qui
travaillent le plus ce sont trois all
fall la plus jeune de l'équipe formée
terre d'ovalie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
car oui 10 heures on earth mais n'hésite
pas tu m'appelles demain si tu vois tout
le dialogue et par auditeur est
beaucoup plus que 35 heures oui mais oui
oui
si on enlève le paddle non
travaillées qu'on veut passer faut payer
les orchies s'est
rendu dans les faire marche arrière vous
aimez faire marche arrière